Guten Abend, Görücü ist mein Name. Ich bin heute zuständige Assistent-Arzt und ich würde gerne mit Ihnen Aufnahme-Aufnahme-Experte durchführen.
Guten Abend, aber ich habe Ihren Namen leider nicht ganz verstanden. Wie ist der Name?
Görücü ist mein Name. Wie bitte?
Görücü.
Görücü, ja.
Was ist das für ein Name?
Das ist ein Türk-Name.
Ach so, Sie kommen aus der Türkei.
Ja, ich komme aus der Türkei.
Ah, Sie sprechen aber gut Deutsch.
Wie lange sind Sie schon in Deutschland?
Seit zwei Jahren bin ich in Deutschland.
Und da haben Sie so schnell gut Deutsch gelernt?
Vielen Dank.
Das ist aber sehr ervorwittlich.
Sehr gut, sehr gut.
Ich habe gehört, dass Ärzte aus der Türkei gute Ärzte sind.
Ja, sie haben total recht.
Ich hoffe.
Bevor wir beginnen, ich habe einige Fragen über Sie, persönliche Fragen.
Wie heißen Sie?
Mein Name ist Alexander Leiter.
Könnten Sie langsam Buchstabinen?
Ich habe einen Vornamen.
Alexander, Anton Ludwig, Emil X, Anton Nordpol, Dora, Emil Richard, Alexander.
Alles klar.
Nachname ist Leiter.
So wie die Leiter, Ludwig Emil Ida, Theodor Emil Richard, Leiter.
Ja, vielen Dank.
Und wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 78 Jahre alt.
Und wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Ich bin geboren am 23. März, 1947.
47 Jahre alt.
Und wie groß sind Sie, Herr Leiter?
1,79 m.
Wie viel wiegen Sie?
82 kg.
Was für Sie zu uns?
Herr Dr. Kiritschü, ich sage mal Kiritschü, so habe ich es dir verstanden.
Ich mache sehr viel Sport.
Ich bin eigentlich immer sehr fit.
Aber ich merke in letzter Zeit, dass wenn ich meinen Blutdruck messe,
ich nehme auch Tabletten, das zeigt mir das Gerät an,
oder gibt Alarm.
Und es piepst immer, als ob der Puls unregelmäßig ist.
Aber ich merke nichts.
Piepst du wegen Puls oder wegen Blutdruck?
Ich weiß es nicht.
Der Blutdruck ist bei mir bei 140 bis 170 kg.
Wann sind Sie letztes Mal in der Blutdruck gemessen?
Gestern und heute Morgen.
Alles klar.
Und wie war heute Morgen Ihr Puls?
Der Puls ist immer zwischen 80 und 90 kg.
Aber das ist bei mir eigentlich immer.
Wenn ich ein bisschen Sport mache, wenn ich mich etwas anstrengen,
dann geht er natürlich auch etwas höher.
Aber ich glaube, wenn ich den Blutdruck messe,
ist es etwas unregelmäßig.
Vielleicht gibt es deswegen das Gerät einen Alarm.
Alles klar.
Haben Sie Beschwerden?
Nein.
Ich sage mal so, ganz leicht, aber ich merke es nicht so.
Ich merke es nur beim Sport.
Ich mache Fitness und ich mache auch Gerätetraining.
Und in den letzten ein paar Wochen merke ich,
dass ich nicht mehr diese Leistung bringen kann,
dass ich früher aufhören muss und ein bisschen Luftnot bekomme.
Sonst haben Sie keine Beschwerden?
Nein, wenn ich merke, dass ich nicht merke, dann höre ich auf.
Aber ich frage mich, woher das kommt, warum das so ist,
weil ich finde, ich fahre eigentlich immer sehr fit.
Haben Sie Herzrasen oder Herzstöpeln, wenn man?
Nein, also ich merke nichts.
Haben Sie nicht mehr alles, klar?
Nach wie vielen Minuten fühlen Sie sich diese?
Normalerweise mache ich so halb, dreiviertel Stunde,
also 45 Minuten.
Und jetzt merke ich so nach 20, 25 Minuten,
dass die Luft etwas knapp wird.
Es ist jetzt schlimm, aber ich merke, da ist ein Unterschied.
Fühlen Sie sich, dass Sie sitzen,
sich müssen oder wie fühlen Sie sich?
Stärke, Atemnot oder nur...
Also nur eine leichte Atemnot, merke so richtige Atemnot,
ist es nicht, aber ich tu mir schwer.
Ich muss etwas mehr Atem, wenn ich merke,
dass ich mich nicht so belasten kann wie vorher auch.
Und dann höre ich einfach auf, aber manchmal klappt es gut,
aber jetzt in den letzten zwei Wochen muss ich vorher aufhören.
Nach wie vielen Minuten ich meine, sich ruhen fühlen Sie sich besser?
Ach so, wenn ich mich ausgeruht habe,
ja, ich denke so nach einer halben Stunde.
Alles klar.
Haben Sie Fieber oder Stufroß oder Nachschweiß bemerkt?
Nein, das ist nicht so.
Und hat sich Ihre Appetit in der letzten Zeit verändert?
Nein.
Haben Sie unwirklich in der letzten Zeit ab oder zu genommen?
Ach so, nein, nicht gleich.
Alles klar.
Aber ich nehme nur dieses Entum.
Okay, wir kommen später zu.
Haben Sie Vorerkrankungen von denen, wie ich es wissen sollte?
Ja, ich habe einen bekannten Humphlohenblutdruck.
Und ich habe vor circa zehn Jahren ein Herzkartett bekommen.
Und ich habe zwei Stents.
Aber das war bisher immer alles in Ordnung.
Hypertonie, seit wann haben Sie die?
Seit über 20 Jahren.
Und vor zehn Jahren wurde bei Ihnen Herzkartette durchgeführt.
Und was war Therapie eigentlich?
Stents.
Ich habe bei Stents bekommen, habe ich ja gesagt.
Sonst haben Sie andere Beklankungen?
Nein, ansonsten gut.
Ich hatte mal eine kleine Prostata-Operation, aber das war jetzt nichts Wichtiges.
Und sonst ist alles okay.
Wann war diese Prostata-OP?
Vor circa vier Jahren.
Sonst wurden Sie operiert?
Nein, ansonsten keine.
Und nehmen Sie, regeln Sie oder bei Bedarf Medikamente ein?
Gegen Hypertonie oder?
Ja, ich nehme jetzt für den Blutdruck zwei Medikamente und einmal As-100.
Einmal As-100 und Aspirin-100.
Und sonst?
Und zwei Blutdruck-Tampletten.
Was ist die Namen dieser Tante?
Ich muss Sie selber mal gucken.
Ich habe es bei mir in der Hosentasche.
Ich hol es mal gerade mal raus.
Kann mir die Namen nie merken.
Ich schaue mal hier einmal Kandesatan.
Welche Dosierung?
8 Milligramm.
Und abends nehme ich die...
Was sind Sie vom Beruf, Herr Leiter?
Schreiner gewesen.
Ich bin jetzt Rentner, aber ich war Schreiner.
Ich habe einen Möbel aufgebaut und Möbel repariert.
Und sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja.
Und haben Sie Kinder?
Ja, ich habe zwei Erwachsene Kinder.
Eine Tochter und ein Sohn.
Sind Sie gesund?
Ja, glücklicherweise.
Haben Sie Stress?
Leiden Sie unter Stress?
Ich stress?
Als Rentner hatten wir keinen Stress.
Nein, nein, die Zeiten sind vorbei.
Alles klar.
Und haben Sie Erkrankungen in Ihrer Familie,
die Sie in der Familie haben,
in meinem nahen Umkreis?
Sind Sie noch Eltern?
Nein, nein, nein.
Sie sind schon vor längerer Zeit verstorben.
Und als Sie vorhin sind Sie gestorben?
Mein Vater hatte einen Herzinfarkt.
Und meine Mutter einen Schlaganfall.
Und rauchen Sie zuzeit?
Nein, nein.
Ich habe nie geraucht.
Und trinken Sie Alkohol?
Sehr, sehr, sehr lange.
Ich fasse nie.
Und ich nehme an, dass Sie keinen Drogen nehmen.
Aber trotzdem muss ich fragen.
Nehmen Sie Drogen?
Nein, meine schlimmsten Droge sind die Zartpitter Schokolade.
Ja, jetzt bei mir die Fragen fertig.
Und haben Sie noch etwas zu hinzufügen
oder Fragen an mich?
Also, was ich jetzt auch in den letzten paar Wochen gemerkt habe,
dass sich die Socken etwas einschnüren an den Füßen
und das an den Unterschenkeln,
sich etwas Wasser ansammelt um die Knöchel herum.
Haben Sie bemerkt eine Schwerung von Ihrer Beine?
An den Knöcheln, ja.
Und die Socken, die Schnüren ein und hinterlassen Spuren?
Alles klar.
Und brauchen Sie, wie viele Kissen zu schlafen?
Also, noch geht es.
Beim Liegen tue ich mich etwas schwer, aber es geht im Moment.
Aber das ist etwas mir aufgefallen.
Die Blutdruckmessen, das Gerät,
zeigt, dass da eine Rhythmusstörung vorliegt.
Und mir tun die Füße etwas anschwellen.
Beide Füße haben Sie das gemacht?
Beide Füße, das habe ich vorher nicht gehabt.
Und manchmal wird es auch ein bisschen leicht eng auf der Brust.
Aber das geht gleich wieder weg.
Wie fühlen sich die Brust-Wicht-Teilen?
Das ist für einen kurzen Moment.
Das ist meistens beim Sport.
Nicht zu sehr anstrengend.
Und in diesem Zeit fühlen Sie sich erstoppen?
Nein, ich hatte ja gesagt, da bekomme ich ein bisschen Luftnot.
Und manchmal ist es auch ein bisschen eng.
Aber das geht nach 15, 20 Minuten wieder weg.
Sind Sie vorständig geimpft?
Ja.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit gereist?
Nein, nein, nein.
Auslern.
Wir machen unsere Reisen jetzt hier in Deutschland.
Alles klar.
Ja, vielen Dank.
Und noch haben Sie etwas zu erwähnen?
Ja, ich wäre froh, wenn Sie vielleicht nachschauen können,
ob es etwas gibt oder muss ich mir Sorgen machen.
Deswegen bin ich jetzt da.
Ja, Sie haben eine gute Entscheidung getroffen, um hier zu kommen.
Jetzt soll ich Sie untersuchen.
Weit untersuchen, muss ich durchführen.
Erstens muss ich eine EKG geben, weil sie ein Rhythmie haben.
Ein Rhythmie verstehe ich nicht.
Ja, Rhythmie bedeutet unregelmäßige Herzschlag.
Ich habe sie nicht gefühlt, aber ich habe sie mit EKG gestimmt.
Machen Sie das noch heute Abend?
Ja, wir machen gleich.
Das ist schön.
Ich bedanke mich.
Danke schön.
Haben Kollegen noch andere Fragen?
Sehr gut, gute Frage.
Schwindelig ist mir nicht.
Beide Sie nachts wach wegen Atemnot?
Nein.
Besuchen Sie regelmäßig zum Hausarzt oder Kardiologe?
Ich bin regelmäßig beim Hausarzt.
Er kontrollierte immer meinen Blutdruck.
Beim Kardiologe war ich vor zwei Jahren das letzte Mal.
Sie wurden unmächtig?
Nein.
Haben Sie beschwerden beim Wasserlassen?
Ich bin regelmäßig beim Urologen, weil die Prostate vergrößert ist.
Ich muss auch öfters nachts zum Wasserlassen raus.
Aber Schmerzen habe ich jetzt keine.
Seit wann haben Sie Herzkranken?
Ich habe gesagt, vor zehn Jahren habe ich Herzkarteter gehabt.
Haben Sie auch Husten dabei?
Husten habe ich nicht.
Der Blutdruck war eigentlich immer ganz gut.
130, 140, 70, 130, 80.
Okay, eine Frage?
Ich sehe niemand mehr.
Wo ist der Doktor?
Werden Sie?
Ich bin da.
Also das EKG ist gemacht.
Das EKG zeigt einen Puls von 72.
Aber es ist unregelmäßig.
Man sieht keine Pewelle.
Worauf geht es?
Zum Beispiel.
Hat der Patient vorher aber nicht gehabt?
Wegen Hypertonie.
Hargiumiopathy meine ich.
Nein, nein, nein.
Keine Diagnose.
Können wir Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch erst mal?
So, Doktor.
Herr Oberhals, ich habe einen neuen Patient aufgenommen.
Ich würde gerne Ihnen vorstellen.
Sehr gerne, dann legen Sie mal los.
Vielen Dank.
Es geht um Herr Alexander Leiter.
Er ist 78 Jahre alt.
Am 23.
3.
1947 geworden.
1 Meter 79 Metern groß.
82 Kilogramm.
Er stellt sich in der Notaufnahme
wegen seit 2 Wochen
eine bestehende Ermütung nach dem Sport vor.
Bequetschen.
Er hat auch leichter Atemnot nach dem Sport bemerkt.
Er hat eine Belastungs- und Dispünö.
Belastungs- und Dispünö.
Er muss 30 Minuten ausruhen,
damit er besser geht.
Damit er ihm besser geht.
Er hat auch
bei den Füßen
eine Schwellung bemerkt.
Er hat die Ödem bemerkt.
Er hat die Ödem ausgeprägt.
Er hat eine Unterschenkel- oder Knöchel-Odem.
Er hat eine Oberschenkel.
Er hat eine Stauungsdämmer.
Er hat die Stauungsdämmer.
Er hat einen Knöchel-Odem.
Er hat keine Catique.
Er hat beide Seite Knöchel-Odem.
Er hat diezeiten 17 Jahre
Vor 20 Jahren wurde bei ihm eine Herzkatheter durchgeführt.
Dann haben wir zwei Stände gehabt.
Vor 20 Jahren oder vor 10 Jahren?
Vor 10 Jahren.
Und den Blutdruck hat er?
Seit 20 Jahren habe er Hypertony.
Vor 10 Jahren habe er Herzkrankheit.
Eine Herzkrankheit?
Sie meine eine coronare Herzkrankheit.
Haben Sie gefragt, ob er auch einen Herzinfarkt hatte?
Ja, er hatte Herzinfarkt, wegen Herzinfarkt.
Er hatte zwei Stände bekommen.
Sicher, dass er einen Herzinfarkt hatte?
Er hatte eine Herzkatheter bekommen.
Herzkatheter und zwei Stände.
Er hat eine Herzkrankheit.
Er hat ein Herzinfarkt.
Er sei Schnarrie.
Er sei zu Röntner vor Herr Schnarrie.
Schreiner.
Ah, R E I N E R.
Das ist aber egal.
Er sei fürheiert.
Er habe zwei gesunde Kinder.
Mhm.
Ja.
Und diese Angabe durch den Amelsten.
Sind Sie fertig?
Ich hätte noch ein paar Fragen zu den Patienten.
Gerne.
Hat er nur Luftnud, oder hat er auch manchmal eine instabile AP?
Oder strahlt es aus?
Er hat eine Belastungsdyspnö.
Er habe Belastungsdyspnö, aber hat er auch eine Belastungsangina.
Belastungsangina, ja.
Er hat leichter.
Hat er?
Ja.
Okay.
Er hat eine Belastungsangina.
Gut.
Hat er noch mal, haben Sie gefragt, ob er in den letzten zehn Jahren noch mal einen Herzkatheter
hatte, oder noch mal einen Herzinfarkt vielleicht hatte?
Haben Sie nicht gefragt.
Haben Sie nicht gefragt, okay.
Aber, ich habe gefragt, wo denn Sie operiert haben, hat er Sie erwähnt, muss ich sagen?
Er hat verneint, dass er operiert wurde.
Gut.
Was meinen Sie, was der Patient hat?
Sie haben eine EKG gemacht?
Ja, EKG.
Auf EKG gibt es keinen P-Wähler.
Im EKG, nicht auf EKG.
Im EKG gibt es keinen P-Wähler und unregelmäßige Q-Areskomplex.
Das sieht vorhoffeliment, Artilalfibulation.
Das sieht aus wie ein vorhoffeliment, okay.
Ja, das sieht auch wie ein vorhoffeliment.
Wie ist der Puls?
Ist es schnell oder langsam?
Es sieht 70 aus, als nicht tachikalbische.
Als er ist nicht tachiaritmisch.
Er ist normalfrequent.
Normalfrequenz, ja.
Normalfrequent.
Also, das heißt, Sie gehen von einem normalfrequenten Vorhofflimmern aus, okay.
Und diese Beschwerde durchstabilt einen Genapektor, wegen dieser Angaben durchstabilt einen Genapektor hin.
Was hat er jetzt?
Sie sagen, er hat jetzt eine Abotomie bei Vorhofflimmern.
Jetzt sagen Sie, er hat eine stabile Angena.
Was ist das jetzt?
Weil er habe Belastung, das könnte auch sein.
Normalerweise geht es so.
Sie geben eine Verdachtstiagnose oder ihre Arbeitstiagnose an und danach kommen ihre Differenzialdiagnose.
Das war meine Verdachtstiagnose, Stabilangena pektores.
Das ist aber ein Symptom, das ist aber keine Erkrankung.
Warum hatte die Angena pektores?
Stabilangena pektores ist nicht ein...
Ja, okay, Stabilangena pektores ist aber ein Symptom, das beschreibt eine Symptomatik.
Das ist keine Erkrankung.
Das heißt, Sie müssen jetzt eine Erkrankung angeben.
Dann wird er mal so vollbühren, er hat eine stabile Angena pektores bei Verdacht auf Progres der bekannten KKK,
Coronaheizerkrankung.
Also das ist Ihre Verdachtstiagnose, ja?
Ja.
Warum hat er Belastungsdüstpnö?
Das heißt, bei Progres der KKK und Herzinsuffizienz.
Beginnender Herzinsuffizienz, so würde ich das formulieren.
Denn er hat beim Liegen keine Düstpnö, es ist nur eine Belastungsdüstpnö.
Welche Nyhag-Klassifikation ist das?
Eins.
Eins, zwei, drei, vier, fünf, sechs.
Bestimmt nicht drei und vier.
Eins oder zwei?
Ja, eigentlich.
Kein Scepton war eins, dann zwei.
Jetzt ist es nicht mehr zwei.
Wir sind der Arzt, Sie müssen das wissen.
Sie haben den Patienten untersucht.
Und können wir nachher gleich nochmal fragen.
Alles klar.
Okay, was sind Ihre weitere Differenzialdiagnose?
Sie gehen jetzt von einem Progres der KKK aus, mit einer Arytmie und einer Herzinsuffizienz.
Okay, was haben Sie noch für eine Diagnose?
Das könnte auch Lungenembolie sein.
Könnte auch Lungenembolie sein, ja, wo?
Und eine Pneumonie könnte auch sein.
Luftnot, Pneumonie, das ist eine, ich meine, ich habe keine Pneumonie.
Bewochen, genau, alter Mann.
Und alter Mann.
Woran denken Sie noch bei alten Menschen?
Krebs, muss ich denken.
Natürlich, immer?
Ja.
Was war ein Krebs?
Das könnte auch eine Lungenkrebs, Bronchial-Kanzelnum könnte sein.
Bronchial-Kanzelnum kann es sein, ja, wo natürlich.
Was noch?
Noch mal etwas Kardiales.
Was gibt es im Herzen noch?
Herz.
Das geht immer so auf und zu?
Ja, auch auf der Klappe oder insuffizienz?
Eine Klappe insuffizienz, ja, kann eine Ortenklappe insuffizienz sein.
Das kann eine Trich-Hospital insuffizienz sein.
Das kann aber auch eine Mittalklappe insuffizienz sein.
Das heißt, Sie hören den Patienten ab, auskultieren die Herz-Töne
und dann können Sie ganz genau sagen, welche Klappe, welches Herz-Geräusch hat
und dann kann man das richtig zuordnen.
Mit Echo.
Echo ist nur eine Bestätigung.
Stimmt, das kommt von Abhören, dann haben Sie schon Ihre Diagnose.
Sie brauchen kein Echo, um eine Diagnose zu stellen.
Echo bestätigt Ihren Verdacht.
Ja, historische, historische.
Das kann man auch schön hören beim Auskultieren.
Sie müssen doch machen und haben eine Frage, eine Eskateologe.
Okay, aber woran muss man noch denken, am Herzen?
Ein Orten-Anarchist machen.
Orten, ja.
Oder Orten-Disektion, okay.
Er hat keinen Schmerzen, aber ja, Erartung ist immer.
Und Lunge vielleicht noch mal?
Lunge.
Er hat nie geraucht, aber es kann sich auch...
COPD.
Ein Lungen im Physiom sich geben.
Ja.
Okay.
Noch mehr?
Diagnose oder haben die Kollegen vielleicht nochmal die Kollegen mal zu Hilfe fragen.
Das sagen die anderen Kollegen noch dazu.
Andere Diagnose.
Das war echt erst mal.
Okay.
Ja, das war der Kollege, sie sind durchgefallen.
Ja.
Wir können jetzt ein bisschen eine kleine Analyse machen,
wenn die Kollegen einverstanden sind.
Dr. Mahmthavis auch da, oder dürfen wir eine kleine Analyse machen.
Ist nicht mehr da.
Erstens, das war jetzt ein Patient, der war vor zwei Tagen da.
Er hat wirklich ein neu aufgetretenes Phochoflimmern.
Und das ist wahrscheinlich der Grund, warum er eine Belastungsdyspne hat.
Und das ist ein Zeichen für eine beginnende Herzinsuffizienz.
Er hat NH2, diese Einstufungen müssen Sie ganz genau lernen für die Prüfung.
Ja.
Die NH2-Klassifikation.
Und die medizinischen Begriffe müssen Sie besser lernen.
Das ist natürlich auf Deutsch, ist es richtig.
Er hat bei Belastung Luftnot.
Aber wenn Sie Arzt-Arztgespräch machen,
müssen Sie schon die medizinischen Begriffe benutzen.
Ja.
Das Zweite ist, wenn der Patient Druck auf der Brust hat,
dann muss man immer natürlich an eine KHK denken.
Der Patient hat ja schon eine KHK, weil er Stands hat.
Und dann muss man auch daran denken, ob diese KHK sich verschlimmert hat.
Das nennt sich ein Progres der KHK.
Eine Verschlechterung der KHK.
Und da muss man natürlich nochmal schauen, wie Sie sagen,
Echo, EKG und sich überlegen, ob man nochmal einen Herzkatheter machen muss.
Der Patient hat neu aufgetretene Knöchelödem, also Unterschenkelödem.
Also wenn man nochmal zusammenfasst, Unterschenkelödem.
Belastungsdüsbne und eine neu aufgetretene Rhythmusstörung.
Also spricht das schon eher für eine kardiale Dekompensation
bei neu aufgetretenem Vorhof Lehmann.
Denn die Wahrscheinlichkeit bei Patienten über 70 Jahre
ist groß, dass man ein plötzliches oder spontanes Vorhof Lehmann bekommt.
Und oft merken die Patienten das nicht.
Wenn sie den Puls nicht messen, hat es an seinem Blutdruck-Messgerät gemerkt,
dass der Puls unregelmäßig ist.
Und das hat ihn beunruhigt, also ist er zum Arzt.
Also das heißt, Sie müssen jetzt ein bisschen die Diagnose
und die Therapie von Vorhof Lehmann kennenlernen.
Das heißt, welche Sorte von Vorhof Lehmann gibt es?
Ein intermittentes Vorhof Lehmann, ein permanentes Vorhof Lehmann,
ein chronisches Vorhof Lehmann.
Und wie stellt man die Diagnose?
Und wie ist die Therapie bei Vorhof Lehmann?
Es gibt mehrere Möglichkeiten, eine Rhythmusstabilisierung,
eine Frequenzstabilisierung.
Und er ist ja enormer Frequent, das heißt, die Frequenz ist in Ordnung,
als versucht man den Rhythmus zu stabilisieren.
Irgendwie macht man das als erstes.
Was macht man, um den Rhythmus zu stabilisieren bei Vorhof Lehmann?
Medikamentös.
Medikamentös ist eine Möglichkeit, wenn der Patient aber sonst gesund ist.
Eine Elektrokardioversion.
Genau, wenn er stabil ist und das Vorhof Lehmann neu ist,
dann würde man als erstes natürlich eine Elektrokardioversion probieren.
Wir bestimmen, ob eine Grinsel im Herz...
Und wie machen Sie das?
Mit endo-Echo.
Trans-asophagial-Echo.
Genau, ein TEE, ein Bluckecho oder ein trans-asophagiales Echokardiogramm.
Richtig.
Und, was müssen wir noch, Medikamentös machen?
Das Blut verdünnen, also antikoragulieren.
Und da gibt es welche Möglichkeiten?
Direkt antikoragulieren dürfen wir geben.
Welches?
Zum Beispiel elikuis, lexiana, davigatran.
Das sind Handelsnamen.
Sie müssen das mit den Wirkstoffen sein.
Davigatran.
Elikuis, wie heißt der Wirkstoff bei elikuis?
Apixaban.
Apixaban, ja.
Und bei lexiana?
Und lexiana ist was?
Eduxaban.
Okay, warte, eins haben wir noch.
Xarelto ist was?
Xarelto ist...
Xarelto war opf-oxaban.
Was hat man früher sehr oft gegeben?
Mocuma.
Oder Varparin, genau.
Und bei akut, wenn du eine frische Diagnose hast, was gibst du dann?
Bauchspritze?
Klexan...
Ein niedermolekulares Heparin.
Zum Beispiel, lexan, endepthoparin.
Aber es gibt natürlich auch andere Heparine, ja.
Genau.
Kompliziert, ja, schwierig.
Sie sind kein Facharzt für Kondysikatologie, oder?
Was haben Sie früher gemacht?
Ich habe keine Facharztinologie,
aber ich habe in der Türkei, in Nutzaufnahme gearbeitet.
Aber ich bin...
Dann müssen Sie das können, mein Lieber.
Also, Sie schauen sich an, Vorhof Limmern.
Sie schauen sich an die Einstufungen der Herzinsuffizienz.
Welche Sorten von Herzinsuffizienz gibt es?
Eine ischibische Kardiomyopathie, dilatative Kardiomyopathie,
obspektive Kardiomyopathie, eine Rhythmogene,
und eventuell eine Rhythmo-Kardiomyopathie,
dann gibt es jetzt auch eine neue Bezeichnung der Herzinsuffizienz.
Hefpef, hefref, so ähnlich heißen die,
da müssen Sie auch noch mal gucken, was das genau bedeutet.
Ja, sehr gut.
Warum, warum, warum können wir die Frage noch mal...
Momentan mit Bukinchox-Hestes-Karpen-Sabe,
ich kann mir das nicht anhören als Kardiologe.